combien de soldats russes sont morts à
Mariva le soir du Nouvel An suite à des
frappes de l'armée ukrainienne après
avoir annoncé un premier bilan de 63
morts le ministère de la Défense russe
évoque désormais 89 disparus de nouveau
corps ayant été retrouvés dans les
décombres un bilan loin de celui évoqué
par l'armée ukrainienne qui revendique
400 décès côté russes à Samara en Russie
d'où était originaire la plupart des
victimes le choc et la tristesse ont
gagné la population la colère aussi
parfois pour expliquer ce lourd bilan
les autorités pointent du doigt la
responsabilité des soldats russes il est
déjà évident que la cause principale et
l'allumage et l'utilisation massive par
le personnel de téléphone portable à
porter des armes ennemies contrairement
à l'interdiction dans le don-basse
l'armée russe peine de plus en plus face
à la résistance ukrainienne dans une
vidéo diffusée par The Guardian le chef
du groupe mercenaire Wagner aux ordres
du Kremlin admet même sa difficile
progression dans la reconquête de la
ville de backmouth dans le Dombas
et avec nous Gautier robinsky en plateau
bonjour Gauthier la Russie qui
communique donc sur le nombre de morts
oui c'est inédit puisque vous savez que
pendant longtemps c'est-à-dire à peu
près 5 mois du côté des autorités russes
on était resté à un nombre de victimes
ridiculement bas par ridiculement bas et
malheureusement faux c'est à dire que
évidemment les pertes étaient minimisées
qu'il fallait convaincre la population
que cette affaire allait même si on ne
l'avait pas réglé en une semaine qu'elle
est elle allait être réglée rapidement
malgré tout que l'Ukraine n'était qu'un
qu'une sorte de furoncle au sud de la
Russie qui allait rapidement être
éradiquée tout ça n'a pas marché alors
pourquoi y a-t-il aujourd'hui cet
échange ou plutôt cette volonté de
communiquer volonté de communiquer
d'ailleurs dans des circonstances
particulières vous avez vu que le
Kremlin reconnaît vous avez dit 89 morts
mais avec une attention particulière
pour ceux qui se servent du téléphone
portable c'est-à-dire les soldats la
question est la suivante est-ce qu'il
s'agit bien des téléphones portables que
les soldats utilisent de manière
contraire
dérèglement interne à l'armée pour
rappeler leurs parents pour appeler leur
femme pour appeler leurs proches et
souvent on le sait par les
communications qui ont été interceptées
pour dire leur malheur pour pour dire
leur angoisse pour dire la façon dont
ils sont engagés dans cette guerre et
leur ignorance quant au but et aux
objectifs alors soit ça dénote cela et à
ce moment-là le Kremlin a envie au fond
de réprimer c'est-à-dire annoncer les
pertes en disant c'est pas notre faute
c'est pas la faute de la direction c'est
pas la faute du Kremlin c'est la faute
des soldats qui ne respectent pas la
règle il rejette la faute sur eux et oui
et donc en principe ça permet la
répression ça on creuse qu'on peut dire
aussi c'est que si le règlement n'est
pas respecté c'est aussi d'une certaine
manière le commandement ne s'est pas le
faire respecter et peut-être que tant
mieux parce que ces soldats sont encore
plus susceptibles de déserter s'ils
n'ont pas cette soupape qui consiste
pour une armée ces problématique pour
une armée de savoir que c'est
communications pouvant être et
interceptées et elles ont été plusieurs
fois par le passé notamment par les
forces ukrainiennes ça complique la
chose simplement il faut y voir me
semble-t-il une moyenne pour le Kremlin
d'annoncer une forme de répression
vis-à-vis de ceux qui se seront servis
de leur portable personnel puisqu'il
s'agit de ça pour joindre leurs proches
leurs familles et c'est une manière
aussi de cacher les critiques puisqu'il
est elle commence à émerger y compris au
sein même du pouvoir et puis on a vu ses
habitants très meurtri parce que il y a
ce bilan de 89 morts il y a des sources
en Ukraine qui parlent de 400 morts oui
alors elles sont peut-être exagérées
mais de toute manière si vous voulez à
partir du moment comme vous l'avez dit
ou le Kremlin reconnaît des des
explosions plutôt des des morts en masse
de son côté ça veut dire
qu'effectivement la volonté à la fois de
reconnaître mais c'est très dangereux
pour le Kremlin et surtout comme vous
l'avez dit de prendre prétexte de ce qui
s'est passé pour verrouiller vous savez
que par exemple parmi les nationalistes
qui sont tranquilles dans leur canapé à
Moscou il y en a beaucoup qui disent il
faut fusiller ceux qui ont été soit
déserteurs soit qui n'ont pas respecté
les consignes ça peut être ça et pendant
un moment ça peut vouloir dire que le
Kremlin se défaut sur des soldats on
sait dans quelles conditions il se
battent on sait dans quelles conditions
j'allais dire politique et morale ils
sont investis et engagés sur ce terrain
ça peut être un moment de répit et de
dire vous voyez bien il y a des traîtres
au sein de notre patrie et c'est très
trifau les éradiquer c'est tout le
problème du fonctionnement d'un régime
fascistoïde qui a en permanence besoin
de se trouver des boucs émissaires et
des ennemis merci beaucoup gaut